depuis plusieurs semaines après la
fermeture des commerces la mise en place
des gestes-barrières et le confinement
s'organise la seconde étape pour
répondre à la crise sanitaire le port
des masques pour chaque français si
l'état a répondu en partie à ces
pénuries en proposant à partir du 11 mai
prochain 20 millions de masques lavables
vendu 5 euros qui seront à disposition
des français notamment dans les bureaux
de tabac aujourd'hui ce sont les grands
groupes alimentaires qui met tout en
oeuvre pour proposer à leurs clients des
masques de protection à partir du 4 mai
prochain les magasins intermarché et
netto vont mettre en vente 100 millions
de masques de protection thierry
cotillard le patron de ses enseignes a
expliqué au parisien comment allait se
dérouler la distribution 10 millions de
ces masques seront réservés à nos pme
partenaires fournisseurs agriculteurs et
ses trois millions seront distribués par
nos adhérents au niveau local et 7
millions au niveau national les
particuliers pourront quant à eux s'en
procurer sous réservation nous allons
mettre à disposition de nos clients 90
millions de masques chirurgicaux à prix
coûtant à partir du 4 mai mais un
système de réservation et mis en place
dès ce mercredi 29 avril
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas les
vendre en rayon car cela serait
difficilement gérable quant au prix de
vendre ses magasins ont décidé de se
joindre à la solidarité nationale et de
ne pas profiter de la situation pour
réaliser des bénéfices
nous ne ferons pas de marche dessus ils
seront vendus à prix coûtant à moins de
30 euros la boîte de 50 masques soit 59
centimes l'unité un geste fort que
d'autres marques pourrait suivre alors
intermarché va vendre des masques à 60
centimes tout le monde doit-il suivre
alors est ce que tout le monde doit
suivre allez raymond dans moi ce que
j'aime bien lens qui dès c'est l'idée de
la concurrence ça veut dire que si
intermarché aujourd'hui mon des masques
à 60 centimes peut-être que carrefour
demain vendra des masses 4 50 centimes
et peut-être que leclerc londres à des
masques à 30 centimes et cetera et
cetera
moi ce que j'adore dans cette idée c'est
qu'il va y avoir de la concurrence et
j'espère que les gagnants ça va être le
consommateur voit ça c'est ce que j'aime
bien après ce que je déplore c'est que
ce soit à nous français d'acheter les
masques voilà c'est chiant voilà ils ont
parlé de masques à 5 euros
ils ont parlé de masques c'est quand
même chiant que ce soit nous d'acheter
du masque et du gel normalement c'est
normalement si l'on parle de faire mais
moi je suis pour cette idée j'aime pas
si c'est ça la question
j'adore cette idée j'aime bien très bien
l'hiver des rhumes je suis content du
réseau téléphonique alors je suis contre
ces piles et pourquoi
d'abord parce que je trouve qu'elle est
pdg de toutes les chaînes en semant qui
viennent faire quasiment leurs
publicités pour des mois je vendais
mascate et le prêt at elle pris ces
carrés quasiment ils viennent faire le
buzz autour des masses à 500
profondément deuxièmement ces masses qui
sont pas chères d'accord mais très
franchement cyril entre des masques
qu'on achète en ce temps
massi sous contrôle et ses masques en
grand public moi je ne demande pas
vraiment les contrôles est-ce qu'ils
sont conformes mais ce cas toutes les
garanties mais selon me g et la descente
et laissez moi juste finir mais c'est
près de finir les deux longs ne vendent
pas que l'on ne vendent pas à des gens
dans le budget est souvent limité donc
ils n'ont pas le choix et c'est tout à
fait normal on ne leur demande pas des
masses qui seraient moins bons que
d'autres donc contrôler avant l'avant
benjamin castaldi
juste une précision et en fait quand
même il faut avoir la carte du magasin
pour être pouvoir raisonner non pas
d'accord c'est important après faut que
tu arrêtes de dire des bêtises
franchement honnêtement effectivement
non merci
franchement c'est comme pour les dons
ont passé comme pour les dons ne peut
pas crier au loup quand on fait pas et
après hurler quand on fait et puis c'est
quand même très bien que des enseignes
mais des masques à 60 centimes je te
rappelle quand même que ces masques la
retrouver sous le manteau sur internet à
2 3 4 5 euros donc c'est très bien pour
le coup c'est très bien après
effectivement je pense comme toi je
pense que je pense aussi que c'était à
l'état de le de les acheter mais bon ça
on sait a pas été possible moi juste une
question cyril on n'a pas les médias n'y
a pas de masque quand même cette
enseigne là ils ont trouvé 100 millions
c'est maintenant à priori y en a donc
voilà je n'avais pas donc c'est quand
même voilà alors regarder l'autre bonne
nouvelle ce sont les prix donc les
enseignes se sont en effet engagés à
vendre des marques à prix coûtant à
partir du 4e b c'est ce qu'on disait
avec valérie bénaïm avec vous la semaine
dernière regarder ça cet engagement
c'est quoi c'est de ne pas gagner
d'argent sur la vente des masques
donc les prix on peut être encadrés
comme pour le gel hydroalcoolique serait
trop compliqué en fait de chaque
enseigne à ses propres sources
d'approvisionnement mais le masques à
usage unique ne devrait pas coûter plus
de 1 euro et le masque lavables et
masques lavables il y en à différents
types ils vont coûter entre 2 et 3 euros
c'est-à-dire moins cher que ce qu'on
trouve en pharmacie
alors les chéris c'est vrai que alors
valérie bénaïm vous avez vu ça alors est
ce que vous êtes
est-ce que vous pensez que doit
s'aligner sur les sur les maillots il
devait détrôner choo a cogné il ici même
dans cette émission avec raymond
n'arrêtait pas de dire qu'il ne fallait
pas qu'on fasse du beurre mais les gens
se fassent du beurre sur le dos des
masses le que voilà et que ce soit vendu
à prix coûtant qu'il n'y ait pas de
marge maintenant qui maintenant que
c'est son ami jacques en pensant acheter
des masques à prix coûtant jean
tangibles qui râlent attentes
qu'est ce que tu veux j'ai franchement
ce sont des masques à usage unique et
qu'une imagine tu imagines bien géré
pendant que bien évidemment ils sont aux
normes afnor et que c'est déjà pas donné
des millions de masques à des gens qui
n'ont pas été des marges de veiller à
bien ayant 60 centimes d'euro à usage
humain et on disait un témoin de cette
fois qu'on voulait des masques
réutilisables beaucoup moins cher que 5
euros il montre aux alentours de 2 voilà
donc voilà au moins ils ont réagi
la grande distribution a et asie et là
c'est bien là est la question
la balle est renvoyée au maintien leur
masse 4 et euro
lavable il faut revoir la donne
maintenant et ça parce que tu en sais
qu'il existe des masses il existe des
masques à 2 euros maintenant rené rené
binamé gréement disais que l'on est on
aurait dû nous tenons les filles meurent
d'une mais malheureusement depuis le
début de ce défi de chagny terre c'est
le principe qui en l'espèce d'acuité et
comme ce qui pendant la majeure partie
charles l'état s'est dédouané sur nous
et voilà le sheed accord crédible
mad catz a dit mme puisque depuis le
début on fait ça et moi je suis pas
d'accord djila tu dis ouah kikongo l'on
côtoie le premier cas vous et l'auto
long de la jetée marque à 5-4 mais pas
mais je ne sais pas je déconne pas je
dis qu'on me prouve je dis qu'on me
prouve qu'à une sécurité que les budgets
les plus faibles encore une fois soit
pas ce qu'ils soient placés en situation
d'illégalité mais nous
répondiez quelques mois plus tôt à ercis
calme-toi gilles s'il te plaît non mais
j attends il à résoudre des cantines des
lycées pas des assassins
les mecs s'y mettre des masques en rayon
ils sont quand même et aux autres
géraldine calme et moi tout ça ma chérie
d'un mois que je trouve qu'on les a on
les a suffisamment à chaque fois un peu
stigmatiser la grande distribution
pour le coup la trouvais qu'ils sont
absolument exemplaire
vous avez parlé d'intermarché il ya
leclerc aussi qui va mettre entre 40 et
50 centimes le masque en fait alors de
deux choses d'entraînement formidable
d'émulation et juste juste pour
l'anecdote parce que évidemment il faut
aussi pas partir mais trouve écho le
monde et quand même fou vous savez qu'il
ya aussi le luxe qui va faire des
masques et laura des biens des gens qui
veulent dépenser beaucoup par exemple
fendi pour inciter d'autres marques
fendi par emploie 490 euros qui est déjà
sold out aux et en italie voilà c'est
une révolte quoi ça c'est ça c'est la
folie alors vous avez omis hervé assah à
vomir ça regardez ce que disait le pdg
de carrefour alexandre bompard sur bfm
il hier soir on trouvera dans la semaine
du 4 mai 10 millions de masques pour nos
clients et on a pris deux trois
décisions additionnel moi je veux que ce
soit très simple pour les clients je pas
envie qu'ils commandent sur internet que
ce soit lié à l'or leur carte de
fidélité non ce sont des masses le conte
trouvera aux caisses
on a pris une deuxième décision ça casse
pas en rayon en caisse en caisse pour
justement éviter la cohue pour que ce
soit gérée dans l'ordre deuxième
décision vous savez aujourd'hui les les
boîtes en contiennent 50 50 ça ira trop
vite
et puis c'est trop cher donc on a décidé
de les ré à lotir et de faire des lots
de 5 et de 10 c'est un travail colossal
qu'on va faire daran respectant
évidemment des normes sanitaires qui ont
été contrôlés dont les principes ont été
contrôlés par les autorités sanitaires
avaient prédit le prix le prix sera
inférieur à 0 60 euro alors voilà c'est
ce qu'il a dit donc le pdg de carrefour
alexandre bompard voilà les shihri ya
pas mal il ya pas mal de gens qui
réagissent sur ces masques est ce que
vous n'avez de ce dont vous avez parlé
giraldi manier des masques donc de haute
couture à combien 190 euros le m oui par
exemple il y en a même un qui a été fait
ce qu'on appelle là c'est des matchs
spéciaux anti anti coded
mais sinon c'était la mode pendant la
fashion week quand il ya eu la phase un
comique juste d'aléria est d'ailleurs à
mon avis qui a été un gros foyers de
propagation aussi du virus est là il
mettait les masques anti-pollution que
faisait les créateurs effectivement les
craintes qu'au rebond aussi inventer des
masques un peu luxe contre contre le
copier voilà et moi je fais d'accord
avec raymond c'est pas scandaleux si
après tout s'il ya des gens au très très
riches qui ont envie d'acheter des
masques très très très très cher des
larges et l'économie tu as fait des
emplois les qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout
vraiment vraiment au point de vue j'ai
vu des masses contre toi géraldine du
dos d'une autre marque j'ai vu des
matches qui sont montés à 700 euros
quand tu mets 500 euros devant ta bouche
degré de deggo il est ou pour mettre 700
balle devant ta bouche pour protéger
notre degré de ces deux joueurs qui
regarde moi je peux mettre un masque
vuitton fendi donne une fois de plus je
vais être démago à 700 balle et autre
chose avec les 700 bat mais ça veut dire
regarde moi je suis en mémoire ces gens
là j'ai beau me mais rené bonnet d
emploi il fait marcher qui a déjà une
idée qui n'est pas le nôtre qui la
jarrie si on ne crée pas les copains rue
alors eh non mais c'est vrai que des
masques à 900 euros 700 euros 160 euros
c'est vrai que c'est complètement fou
vous comprenez ça benjamin castaldi a
même pas non là on répond pas du tout
non mais après raymond est toujours un
peu démago on est content d'avoir une
belle paire de chaussures je dis pas non
plus mais le dit c'est vrai après je
suis d'accord avec toi là pour le coup
c'est vraiment du foutage de en plus et
c'est au nez et à la barbe de tout le
monde pose c'est le cas de le dire
c'est tout ça c'est bon on va savoir que
tu as un masque à celle s'emballe je
pense que c'est un peu indécent que
franchement oui pareil pour les montres
pareil pour les sacs
arrêtez d'être il n'a pas fait des
montres pour lutter contre le virus l'a
bien sûr on le lui lutter contre un
fléau et non janvier la valeur 'marché'
d'économie il tant mieux voilà valoriser
les règlements sont bien le mot ces
signes et inique voilà c'est ça le bourg
quelqu'un avait tué défendre que l'eau
en étudiant joli os
valérie benaïm non mais voilà ce que
j'ai raté c'est vrai à la raison c'est à
dire qu'effectivement si quelqu'un a
envie de m neuf cent mille euros 1200
euros pour un masque c'est son problème
à lui mais évidemment aux yeux des
autres c'est ça paraît totalement cimic
sais c'est une passe vers de dire
regardez moi ce que je peux faire avec
mon âge c'est n'importe quoi
alors allez merci vous avez vu sur les
masses 90% des gens disent voilà qu'il
faut faire le prix des masques aux le
moins cher possible